[Musique]
2 500 votre quotidien au lancement du
concours à plus de 2000 votes par jour
vous avez été des milliers à vous
intéresser à la chanson préférée des
réunionnais ce soir à 20h30 sur notre
site en facebook live ce sera donc la
finale
on saura enfin quelle chance ont fait le
plus vibrer vos coeurs les deux
finalistes sont cascavelle du groupe
cayambe avec sara leal dans le coeur
soleil est haute et grand-mère de
ousanousava c'est vous qui votez c'est
vous qui les avaient emmenés en finale
parmi 32 chansons il y avait réfléchi à
loyat y avait même fait l'amour il y
avait pire mal de l'année et loire au
bato fou
le but en vrai n'est pas de dire c'est
elle qui est meilleur que l'autre ou
intel n'ont réellement le but c'est sur
les réseaux sociaux sur des plateformes
où sont les personnes plus jeunes de
leur faire découvrir ou redécouvrir des
chansons du patrimoine qui fondent
l'identité réunionnaise
c'est le pôle régional des musiques
actuelles qui avait sollicité ce
concours et qui avait parmi 1000 titres
présélectionner les 32 chansons pour
cette finale en live
il y aura donc des surprises des
rencontres avec fred espel pierrot
witold thierry gauliris frédéric joron
et bien d'autres ce sera de la culture
du positif en partage
[Musique]